a sidewalk like any other in canada
now the scene of the country's latest
hate crime and another makeshift
memorial for the dead
all of the victims in this matter are
members of the same family
the deceased include a 74 year old
female
a 46 year old male a 44 year old female
and a 15 year old female one nine year
old male
the soul survivor remains in hospital
with serious
injuries not considered life-threatening
i'm also able to tell you at this time
that based on information collected
during the course of the investigation
we believe that this was an intentional
act
and that the victims of this horrific
incident were targeted
we believe the victims were targeted
because of their islamic faith
canada's government has been worried
about race-based and religious attacks
for years
let me be clear this was an act of mass
murder perpetrated against muslims
against londoners
and rooted in unspeakable hatred this
act of islamophobia this
act of unspeakable hatred must be
followed by acts of compassion
acts of kindness acts of humanity
acts of solidarity empathy justice
and above all love the family was out
for an evening stroll when the suspect
nathaniel veltman
drove his pickup truck at them as they
waited to cross at an intersection
he was wearing a body armor style vest
when police arrested him at a nearby
shopping mall
high profile attacks have happened
before
in 2018 a driver killed 10 people in
toronto a year before
six people were shot dead at a mosque in
quebec
this attack comes days after protests
over indigenous schools
took a dramatic turn demonstrators in
toronto tore down the statue of egerton
ryerson
the architect of the residential school
system that racially abused
indigenous communities for more than a
hundred years
the discovery of the remains of 215
children in a mass grave
at a school run by the government and
the catholic church has sparked
nationwide anger but it's feared there's
more to come
we know that there were probably
lots of sites similar to kamloops that
are going to come to
light in the future and
we need to begin to prepare ourselves
for that
canada is trying to deal with its legacy
of mistreating first nations communities
amid a surge in right-wing extremism
targeting minority groups
a 2020 study funded in part by the
canadian government
warned of the growing and unprecedented
influence
of white supremacists hate groups and
militias
inside canada zain basravi al jazeera